bild
bild meinung chef philipp jakob ist
jetzt bei uns im studio philipp schön
dass du da bist die politik ist gerade
in der sommerpause aber trotzdem kommt
jetzt doch bewegung in die sache ganz
genau wir können jetzt hier bei bild
live exklusiv verkünden dass das
kanzleramt für diesen donnerstag dem 14
juli eine notfall runde einberufen hat
um über die gaskrise zu sprechen konkret
sind die chefs der staatskanzleien
geladen also die wichtigsten mitarbeiter
der ministerpräsidenten der länder und
die sollen zusammen einerseits mit dem
kanzleramtschef wolfgang schmidt und
auch mit klaus müller von der
bundesnetzagentur über die energie krise
sprechen also im prinzip einen tag
nachdem wie hier im bild verkündet haben
das bild kämpft nachdem wir auf der
seite 2 dem kanzler aufgefordert haben
dass es so einfach nicht mehr geht das
hat uns eine familie sehr dramatisch
geschildert wird jetzt endlich gehandelt
dass zumindest ein erster schritt die
chefs der staatskanzleien werden sich
zusammenschalten mit dem kanzleramtschef
und dann geht es ganz konkret darum was
macht deutschland wenn uns das gas
womöglich komplett abgedreht wird wie
viel müssen wir einsparen das wollen die
länder wissen von der bundesregierung
gibt es überhaupt konzepte wie man
einspart wo man einspart damit die
bevölkerung ja vorbereitet ist damit die
wirtschaft vorbereitet ist und wieviel
cast kriegen wir womöglich über
ersatzlieferung überhaupt nach
deutschland
also diese runde wird am
donnerstagnachmittag tagen und jetzt
nachdem wir das publik gemacht haben
kann man natürlich auch zumindest auf
konkretere ergebnisse hoffen denn jetzt
wissen alle teilnehmer weist das
kanzleramt jetzt schauen wir drauf und
wir erwarten auch dass konkrete
ergebnisse vorgelegt werden es hat sich
ein bisschen so an wie ja eine gas mpk
light sozusagen könnte das sogar ein
auftakt sein ja interessanterweise ist
auch eine der forderungen der
unionsländer dass man etwas sich besser
koordiniert in der gaskrise dass bund
und länder zusammen irgendeine art
format schaffen um sich abzustimmen denn
eigentlich ist das ja so dass die
bundesregierung alleine zuständig ist
für die energie sicherheit aber die
länder wollen natürlich mitreden und
genau das könnte man erwarten was du
gerade gesagt hast das comeback der im
liga wird also dass diese runde der
ministerpräsidenten und des
bundeskanzlers und auch einigen
ministern die wir aus der korona krise
kannten die zum teil naja sagen wir mal
für chaos gesorgt hat aber es geht
vielleicht gar nicht anders denn auch
wenn die bundesregierung alleine
zuständig ist betrifft das natürlich
auch die auch die ministerpräsidenten
der länder die müssen sich ja auch
anpassen der gaskrise sie müssen ihren
bürgern ihren parlamenten auch rede und
antwort stehen und wollen sich natürlich
auch das glaube ich kann man auch sagen
profilieren in dieser gaskrise wie man
es beispielsweise von markus söder kennt
also ich glaube wer markus söder erlebt
hat den bayerischen ministerpräsidenten
in der korona krise weiß da erwartet uns
noch einiges auch in der energiekrise
deswegen mal schauen was dabei rauskommt
ob es tatsächlich wieder zum comeback
der mpk kommt was versprichst du dir
ganz konkret welche maßnahmen könnten
dann am donnerstag beschlossen werden
ich
erwarte keine maßnahmen aber ich erwarte
einige antworten denn die fragen mit
denen die unionsgeführten bundesländer
kommen die sind schon ziemlich relevant
denn wir hören jetzt sehr häufig von
wirtschaftsminister harbeck oder anderen
ministern hier soll eingespart werden da
soll eingespart werden aber gibt es
diesen einen zentralen gas sparplan für
deutschland oder gibt es sie nicht was
heißt das denn wenn die nächste gas
alarmstufe ausgerufen wird dann heißt es
ja dann müssen da muss gas rationiert
werden in einigen branchen aber in
welchen branchen und natürlich die große
frage ist kann deutschland damit umgehen
wenn russland einen kompletten
gaslieferstopp verhängt gerade werden
die pipelines gewartet was passiert aber
wenn putin in gas haben nicht wieder
aufdreht oder was passiert wenn er
wieder aufdreht und dann im herbst
wieder zu wir müssen ja dieses auf diese
szenarien vorbereitet sein und man kann
die bürger nicht in der schwebe lasten
vor diesem winter sondern jeder bürger
braucht eine antwort muss wissen dass
die bundesregierung das die länder
vorbereitet sind auf einen wirklich
angespannten winter in dem wir womöglich
mit lukas haben die antworten werden wir
hoffentlich dann am donnerstag bekommen
vielen dank philippi ad hoc bild meinung
chef